I feel like I have to start this
interview with poo poo head oh where
trailer
do you even remember the things that
came out of your mouth that day poo poo
head both of you poo poo heads you're a
worm with a mustache no honestly I went
to bed I put my head on the pillow and I
was like open eyed like oh what has
happened no I'm just kidding uh no
honestly people have asked has it did
that just spring to your mind and I was
like yes actually it really did
I mean how does it feel to be the number
one guy in the group now Time magazine's
number one guy in the group yeah uh I
don't know I kind of feel like Tony
Stark you know I feel like Iron Man
these a couple that the last couple of
days it's been good
I mean Ally truly we can owe this whole
thing to you you were the Whistleblower
here how does that feel and have you
processed that yet
like I I don't know
um I I guess I processed it as well as I
can and it's it's it's it's
Destiny right because it was on it was
unintentional right but and then like
out of all the things out of everyone
right it was Ali that happened to be the
Whistleblower right so it's just
interesting I think I just had a
different perspective than everyone else
like something was off it's not normal
enough outside that you could see
exactly same this whole season is insane
but I didn't really know what was I
didn't know it was that deep I didn't
know anything really but yeah as we head
into this reunion what do you want the
viewers to keep in mind as they watch
the episodes oh just keep in mind
everything that you guys are doing
everyone's doing a great job so far
keeping everything in mind you know I
mean I've seen flashbacks from like
season six this is why this makes sense
and all these Easter eggs so just keep
at it we're nearly there I can't believe
it's three parts but just like get
through it with us and I promise it'll
be worth it and then it sounds like
cameras will be up soon enough do you
think there is room for Sandoval and or
Raquel Rachel to return I mean I'm not
to be the one to tell someone they can't
film and stuff I've been on that end of
the stick before you know I remember
when they tried to exclude me out of
filming and it kind of worked back then
you know as the number one guy in the
group you know I want to be I want to be
the nice number one guy in the group I
don't want to be that girl or you know
they've made their mistakes I'll leave
it up to the girls really to make that
decision uh but it's not going to be me
that's going to be putting my foot down
or anything like that I'll be honest
why do things get to that place where
you lunge across the stage though
oh you're gonna have to watch and see
what that worm with a mustache said to
me you're a worm with a mustache us